The real case for universal basic income
in my view is not financial, it is moral.
To live a satisfying life
a person must spend that life doing
important things such as raising a
family, holding a job that is satisfying
and fulfilling, being a good member of
one's community. For those roles to be
satisfying, people have to have
responsibility for what those
institutions do. Have responsibility for
the decisions they make. One of the
things that the lucky people in society
already have is a life in which they
know they can take responsibility for
their own actions;
they can live the lives they see fit. What
a universal basic income will do is make
that same possibility for a satisfying
life
open to everyone, and that would be a
fulfillment of the American dream that
goes far beyond the usual notions of a
nice house in the suburbs.